[Musica]
[Applauso]
è possibile leggere nel pensiero
il regalo perfetto
Siete riusciti a distinguere qualche
parola o qualche frase scambiata tra le
persone in questa mensa No giusto Bravo
anch'io No non è possibile non è
possibile per diversi motivi Il primo
motivo è perché tutte queste persone
parlano contemporaneamente e anche se si
scambiano discorsi ragionevoli il fatto
che parlino insieme ci rende impossibile
capirli in più si sommano delle
interferenze dei suoni era una mensa
quindi c'era il rumore dei coltelli dei
piatti
Se volessimo sentire quello che ci dice
un gruppetto di persone quello che
stanno dicendo queste persone bisogna
avvicinarsi e cercare di allontanare
tutte quelle altre tutti quegli altri
disturbi tutte quelle interferenze
Proviamo adesso ascoltare quest'altro
audio
Questo è il segnale che emette il nostro
cervello
nel nostro cervello ci sono
86 miliardi di neuroni ciascuno di
questi neuroni interagisce con gli altri
neuroni creando dei Segnali elettrici
ciascuno di questi neuroni può
interagire con fino a 10.000 altri
neuroni
Ora io non sono capace di quantificare
bene cosa voglia dire 86 miliardi quindi
Ho pensato che forse un esempio ci
potesse aiutare
sulla terra ci sono quasi 8 miliardi di
persone quindi per arrivare a fare 86
miliardi
vuol dire che noi dobbiamo considerare
tanti pianeti a terra Quanti 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 e ancora un pochino di più
per poter quindi capire i segnali che
sono emessi dal nostro cervello dobbiamo
cercare di andare molto vicino ai
neuroni isolarne dei piccoli gruppi e
soprattutto Eliminare tutte le
interferenze In termine tecnico questa
interferenze si chiamano rumore
la prima volta che ho capito che il
rumore non è soltanto un segnale sonoro
e quando all'università ho seguito il
corso che si chiama analisi del rumore
nei reattori nucleari
e io non avrei mai immaginato che il
rumore potesse essere importante al
punto da aver addirittura un'intera
insegnamento dedicato alla spiegazione
del rumore in un reattore nucleare
tra l'altro questo corso per me è stato
fondamentale perché il docente che
teneva questo corso è poi il docente con
cui ha fatto la tesi di laurea la tesi
di dottorato ma non basta È una persona
a cui voglio ancora molto molto bene
perché mi ha insegnato mi ha veramente
insegnato
Scusate mi ha insegnato ad amare la
ricerca e mi ha insegnato ad amare
l'insegnamento la trasmissione del
sapere
e mi ricordo questi episodi che che ho
vissuto alla sera io rimanevo spesso
fino a tardi in dipartimento ed era
bellissimo perché se era tardi lui
arrivava prendeva una seggiolina si
sedeva vicino a me e cominciavamo a
ragionare su quello che avevamo scoperto
sulle nuove idee su quello che era il
progetto futuro e voi dovete immaginarvi
che io ero una giovane studentessa e lui
era un professore ordinario di grande
successo quindi era veramente
emozionante
Adesso ho un laboratorio mio
all'università dal 2017 un laboratorio
dove lavoro sui segnali e dove insieme
ai miei studenti ai miei collaboratori
lavoriamo nella proprio nel tentativo di
rimuovere il rumore dai segnali per
pulirli e andare al vero senso dei
segnali e uno degli argomenti che in
questo momento ci appassiona
particolarmente quella della brain
computer interface o bci
con la brain computer interface i
segnali del nostro cervello vengono
registrati
interpretati e questo permette
un'interazione fra l'essere umano e la
macchina il computer
e i neuroni sono tantissimi sono
particolarmente visti e Questo significa
che non è facile no raccogliere questo
segnale quindi La cosa ideale è andare
proprio vicino vicinissimo alla sorgente
dentro nel nostro cervello e la
tecnologia ci permette di fare questo la
tecnologia ci permette di creare degli
elettrodi piccolissimi che si dice
vengono impiantati nel cervello in
questo modo il rumore Le interferenze
ovviamente sono ridotte
c'è un ragazzo che si chiama Nathan
Nathan copeland che adesso ha 36 anni
che nel 2004 ha subito un incidente per
il quale è rimasto paralizzato e non
riesce quindi più a muovere nelle
braccia nelle gambe
aderito un progetto di ricerca da 8 anni
per cui gli si sono si è fatto
impiantare nel cervello questi elettrodi
ora grazie a questi elettrodi nata nei
in grado di comandare col suo pensiero
un braccio artificiale un braccio
meccanico che è in grado di prendere gli
oggetti di sollevarli di spostarli di
bere da solo
ma non solo è in grado anche di
stringere la mano a un'altra persona
Adesso però vorrei un po' un esercizio
da parte vostra vi chiedo di girarvi
verso il vostro vicino e di stringergli
la mano prestando molta attenzione a
questo gesto vedete la mano e vedete le
due mani che si stringono ok
Adesso però immaginate di non sentire la
mano che stringete di non sentire la
temperatura magari diversa dell'altra
persona o anche la pelle liscia o la
leggera peluria che ci potrebbe essere
Ecco la cosa veramente sorprendente di
questa tecnologia E che questi elettrodi
che è Nathan Gli permettono di sentire
quello che tocca permette proprio la
restituzione della sensazione tattile
c'è un altro ragazzo come è Nathan che
ha subito un incidente ed è rimasto
paralizzato e io mi sono emozionata
tantissimo quando l'ho ascoltato quando
ho ascoltato la sua testimonianza perché
raccontava la sua gioia Dopo anni di
immobilizzazione quando è riuscito
finalmente a sentire di nuovo la carezza
sulla mano della propria fidanzata
questa tecnologia è grandiosa Però forse
giustamente vi chiederete ma a noi tutto
sommato cosa cosa cosa riguardano è
molto lontana da noi sono pochissime le
persone che hanno degli elettrodi
impiantati nel cervello Forse per
fortuna anche
però questa tecnologia c'è c'è
tecnologia che ci permette di leggere il
pensiero di registrare i segnali del
nostro cervello banalmente se qualcuno
di voi è andato in ospedale a fare un
elettroencefalogramma ha proprio
sono stati proprio letti i segnali del
proprio cervello ma anche questo è un
po' lontano dalla nostra vita in realtà
Esistono degli strumenti
indossabili che permettono la lettura
del segnale del nostro cervello Questo è
un esempio di questi strumenti sono
strumenti accessibili ormai a tutti
perché hanno dei costi contenuti
100/150 online possono essere comprati
E allora proviamo un po' a capire
insieme che cosa questo strumento ci
potrebbe permettere di fare e ci
permette di fare
adesso abbiamo fatto un piccolo
esercizio che è una simulazione Ok non
sono stata io veramente a comandare
l'accensione delle luci perché in questo
teatro non riuscivo a fare in modo che
si riuscisse a fare ma questo si può
fare con questi strumenti si può fare io
posso pensare di accendere una luce a
destra oppure a sinistra oppure in alto
oppure in basso
con questi strumenti Si può pilotare un
drone quindi farlo muovere salire
avanzare muoversi nello spazio poi ci
sono applicazioni ludiche si può giocare
con un computer oppure si può interagire
con degli altri individui con delle
altre persone in un ambiente di realtà
virtuale
poi ci possono essere delle applicazioni
un po' più Nobili Perché una persona con
disabilità che non riesce a muoversi
autonomamente potrebbe guidare la
propria carrozzella
ora Quali sono i limiti di questa
tecnologia
i limiti sono ancora legati al rumore il
rumore interferisce con il segnale e se
prima ci eravamo posizionati sul
cervello per leggere il segnale alla
sorgente con uno strumento di questo
tipo facciamo più fatica il rumore è
tanto sono tante cose Vi faccio degli
esempi per capire quale tipo di rumore
può interferire con il segnale che
registriamo un rumore è il battito delle
ciglia che peraltro noi non possiamo
neanche controllare più di tanto un
altro rumore è legato al movimento della
mandibola oppure la deglutizione e
questi il battito cardiaco Anche questi
sono rumori che stanno sulla persona Poi
ci sono i rumori dell'ambiente un
esempio molto semplice è la corrente
elettrica la corrente elettrica crea un
interferenza e crea del rumore
questa tecnologia nonostante le
difficoltà di dover pulire dal rumore il
segnale è una tecnologia che entrerà
nelle nostre case così come sono entrati
i braccialetti gli Smartwatch che
misurano i nostri parametri fisiologici
che ci dicono se abbiamo fatto
abbastanza sport che ci dicono se il
nostro cuore Qualche volta c'è qualche
tentennamento
esistono già degli occhiali sui quali
sono inseriti degli elettrodi che
permettono di registrare il segnale del
nostro cervello
Allora leggere nel pensiero si può la
scienza ce lo dice
questa sono io e penso che in questa
foto io avessi due o tre anni
quando ero piccola come di solito tutti
i bambini ero molto attenta a quello che
mi circondava ero molto curiosa
e con la mamma Sono in sala e gioco
faccio un gioco e la mamma mi propone
questo gioco mi dice Indovina il colore
a cui sto pensando E io rispondo rosso
senza esitazione e questo gioco Continua
e mia mamma continua a farmi domande
chiedendomi di indovinare e alla fine
mia mamma mi convince di essere in grado
di comunicare col pensiero e mi convince
che io sono in grado di leggere nel
pensiero
ora Adesso vorrei farvi questa domanda
avete mai detto a qualcuno mi hai
proprio letto nel pensiero alzate la
mano io sì Io sì oh che bello Sì va
bello questo bellissimo e qualcuno vi ha
mai detto anche a voi mi hai proprio
letto nel pensiero A me sì e anche a voi
Perfetto allora mi è riuscita a seguire
in quello che sto per dire
la cosa sorprendente quando realizzi che
qualcuno ti ha letto nel pensiero o che
tu sei stato in grado di leggere nel
pensiero non è soltanto questa
constatazione Ma è quella gioia quasi
tangibile percepibile con i nostri sensi
che ti dà entrare in sintonia con
l'altra persona
Allora io dico che è possibile leggere
nel pensiero anche noi esseri umani
senza la necessità della tecnologia
però vorrei chiarire non vuol dire che
dal nostro cervello escono delle parole
delle frasi e noi le leggiamo come
quando apriamo un libro e andiamo a
leggere il libro non è questo
quello che intendo dire è che noi come
esseri umani possiamo sentire l'altro
possiamo capire come sta l'altra persona
possiamo creare un'interazione pulita
entrare in sintonia con questa persona
il problema qual è
Il problema è sempre del rumore rumore
come prima che tipo di rumore tanti tipi
di rumore ci sono i suoni fastidiosi
esempio l'ambulanza il cane dei vicini
che abbaia al brusio di sottofondo tutti
questi rumori che conosciamo fastidiosi
ma ci sono altri rumori un pensiero
fisso una preoccupazione lo stress del
lavoro
un oggetto vicino che che ci continua a
distrarre
a me succede spesso di tornare a casa
dal lavoro magari anche tardi
e io ho tre figli quindi un bel bagaglio
che quando arrivo a casa hanno voglia di
parlarmi di raccontare e mi raccontano
parlano e però mentre mi parlano io
comincio a pensare Oddio quella Mail
urgentissima a cui non ho risposto e poi
penso dovevo far partire la lavatrice
Adesso i piatti sono sporchi non li ho
puliti c'è la lista della spesa sul
tavolo nessuno è andata a prenderla e
poi in quel momento mi suona il
cellulare cosa succede che i miei figli
mi guardano e mi dicono mamma non ci
stai ascoltando non ci stai ascoltando
è vero
non li sto ascoltando ed è triste
proprio triste che una persona che ti
ama e che tu ami ti dica non mi stai
ascoltando
Allora quello che dobbiamo fare noi è
pulire la nostra vita da tutto il rumore
restaurare una comunicazione con chi ci
sta intorno entrare di nuovo in sintonia
con chi ci sta intorno questo ci
permette di scoprire di nuovo che il
mondo è molto bello Quindi così come io
faccio nel mio laboratorio con i miei
studenti
l'invito è quello facciamo pulizia
rimuoviamo tutte le fonti di rumore che
sono presenti nella nostra vita grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]